at long last we're returning to an old
show of ours but in a brand new way
movie recipes is back and this time it's
been delicious I couldn't stomach any
more that crap I was making at home so
we asked a few celebrity chefs to see if
they could do better and holy SH was
that direct decision in the new series
you'll see Chris and I discussing movies
while talented chefs prepare meals
inspired by them on the community table
channel you can learn more about the
dishes and the chefs who created them so
make sure you check that out and now
without further ado sometimes watching a
movie isn't enough you also want to eat
that movie that's why there's movie
recipes to me giulio today we're with
Chef Dale levitski at cinema in
Nashville Tennessee I was always a
Disney fan growing up for me doing these
dishes was was very easy and a lot of
fun there's there's a lot of different
ways that you can you can take these and
within being food inspired so it's I
could probably make five or six
different dishes for each movie just
because it's you know it's there's a lot
of a material there we have challenged
him with making a dish suitable for a
mad tea-party chef Levitsky has chosen a
list of essential ingredients to do just
that they are rabbit that's what he gets
for being late time only the white
rabbit had more of it and squash to
represent the squash hopes and dreams of
mr. rabbit because you know he's dead
now let's get cooking
I haven't seen Alice in Wonderland in a
long time because this is for me this
was that movie that I saw about two
years too young and it scared the
bejesus out of me is that what scared
you back in the day was the Cheshire Cat
he's like his grin just shows up in the
middle and with no body
creepy definitely crossing my fingers
he's not going to serve his cat
isn't the book supposed to be a lot more
dark like a lot more mature version of
the story and Disney sort of friendly it
up I don't know I read it I read it yeah
actually fairly recently but I don't
remember there being anything else in
one way recent yeah okay yeah I don't
know then I did okay um but falls into
the thing yeah goes into place and then
everything is weird
it has its Lewis Carroll land and you
know how many shrooms did that guy do
probably all of them missing cat takes
his head off well no wonder the movie me
up okay see if this is on YouTube we can
we can edit it out in post that's right
edited post really and the slithy Toves
I did the guy a random Bell in the way
yeah that guy would have freaked me out
if I was like a five-year-old I think
what he's gonna do is make us a team
blood cake animal wise I think it's
gonna be human cat or rabbit human cat
or rabbit I'm near to down to those
three yeah I haven't had humans since I
was like four I haven't had humans since
I saw alive and just wanted to see what
all the fuss was about
alright
you
ready gentlemen all right here we go
look at this hastiness yeah this is
amazing oh man all right oh yeah this
this is Alice in Wonderland so it's down
the rabbit hole okay so there is white
rice with a chamomile tea poached rabbit
loin so with the tea party um he wasn't
on time so I poached the rabbit we also
have some some blackberries some
homemade creme fraiche and some mustard
just a lot of little things you'd find
you'd find in the garden with mr. rabbit
awesome man all right listen also
microgreens so that there get about that
big all right
that is out that is that's I'm there's
actually time all right
he was late for his very important day
yeah yeah there you go boom everything
on this plate yeah connects I've never
had rabbit I'm not sure what what's the
color here in this sauce that's a
blackberry puree like I think I can make
a decent home meal but I just wasn't my
brain would never put all this stuff
together how many plates did you smear
before you got the three you know two
you wanted those two I'm pretty good
it's me Kyle Kyle did it my assistant
Kyle he uh he's a master smear so he did
those good smearing Kyle front to back
excellent smearing
thanks for watching today's episode we
have two more videos with Dale coming
soon and more episodes planned with
other chefs after that make sure you
leave a comment about what movies and
ingredients we should use in the future
and if you want to learn more about the
chefs and the dishes they created for us
click over to the community table
channel and subscribe